four o'clock time for one more rehearsal
in bantam quarter in the capital of
guinea-bissau actor d on china's kasama
directs the nato Stefan team Portuguese
for bondings grandchildren the group
which has more than 100 members of all
ages promotes the culture of
guinea-bissau they've already rescued 23
traditional dances from oblivion boo
complimented vida loca heart of our work
is going to a specific region where an
ethnic group lives and we collect
information about the dance music and
costumes later in bissau the group works
on the dance and on the cultural
components we rescued master yes
complement occasional family since its
foundation in the year 2000 NATO's deben
team has won almost all the local and
national carnival parades gaining
popularity among the youth through
traditional dances and music nitto
stedman team has helped keep children
off the streets and given them an
opportunity megali no suarez de Gama
grew up without parents today he is a
popular percussionist yeah we got on
this soul I used to lead the life of a
street child I hung around in the
streets doing bad things like stealing
but nato's de bon team changed my life
completely when it cools you will that I
mean I video now I'm studying law at the
University vocal added red egg Turkish
Amma's initiative helps teenagers to
discover their own talents and overcome
obstacles in their lives we are upon
finishing answers difficult our next
monday in some classes most of the
children in NATO's devon team are
vendors orphans yes our school the
faculty balan pox they spend almost
seventy percent of their time doing some
work alguna bali
yes skinny and we support children in
terms of education and healthcare group
operation center scolari's estoy bien
bamboos American medicamento the
organization relies solely on shows to
generate income there's no external
support half of the profits go towards
supporting the young dancers such as
Myra Paulina Jew who recently graduated
who's that thrush bus I used to spend
time as a vendor at the market but NATO
Stefan teams help enabled me to go to
school every day now I don't go to the
bonding market anymore I'm too busy at
school gin mill tiempo al fresco NATO
steban team also offers literacy
training for parents and vocational
courses for the young initially went to
Aruba epithelia currently the group has
partnerships with several schools and
training centers we have 10 to 15 young
people attending training courses before
NATO Steben team have already taken
guinea-bissau as culture to Gambia
Senegal and Portugal and to carnival in
Brazil
you